today on the matt walsh show an article
for the washington post
argues that young children should be
exposed to kink
and fetishism uh it'll do them good says
the writer we'll discuss that
madness today and our five headlines
bill cosby has freed from prison gwen
berry finally comes up with a reason for
turning her back on the flag during the
anthem
really bad reason but she has a reason
and the founder of bet
who is a billionaire by the way says he
wants his reparations check and he wants
it now
in our daily cancellation we'll discuss
the efforts to remove quote unquote
confederate statues
from the u.s capitol efforts endorsed by
many republicans who are going to be
canceled today
by me all of that and more today on the
matt walsh show
now we're going to check in with bambi
you know if you're uh
if you're a small business or any size
business you can't afford the risk of
not having your hr in order every
business owner knows this this is
not a fun thing you have to deal with
but you do have to deal with it and
there are
major issues if you don't take care of
it but you didn't start your business
for this reason right because you wanted
to spend time on hr compliance wrongful
termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations so much
red tape you got to deal with
hr managers salaries also aren't cheap
an average of 70 000
a year we're talking about that's why
you need bambi bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e
was created specifically for small
businesses you can get a dedicated hr
manager
uh also craft hr policy and maintain
your compliance
all for just 99 dollars a month uh so
you compare that to
70 000 a year i think it's obvious which
is better your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email or real-time
chat
from on-boarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business
and they help you manage your employees
day-to-day so go to bambi.com walsh
right now to schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com spelled b-a-m-b-e
dot com slash walsh if you've been
living a life
of oblivious serenity perhaps out in a
wilderness somewhere or in a cave in the
desert maybe in a bubble under the sea
you may be surprised that a headline
like this was published anywhere the
headline
yes kink belongs at pride and i want my
kids to see it
and even when you find out that this was
published you may assume that it was
featured on some sort of
far left blog and written by a fringe
militant
crazy lgbt activist you'd be right about
the second part of that and even the
first except in this case
the far left blog goes by the name the
washington post
yes this this open and explicit advocacy
for exposing children to sexual
fetishism and kink
did grace the pages of what was once at
some point in the past i'm told
considered a reputable and mainstream
newspaper at no point in my life but i'm
told that at some point that was the
case
the article written by lauren roello
we'll have more on her in a minute
encourages parents to do as she does
with her own young children
bring them out to pride events in order
to encounter half-naked men
acting out their depraved sexual
fantasies in public
she writes speaking of her experience at
a pride march in philadelphia five years
ago she writes quote
when our children grew tired of marching
we plopped onto a nearby curb
just as we got settled our elementary
schooler pointed in the direction of
oncoming floats
raising an eyebrow at a bare-chested man
in dark sunglasses
whose black suspenders clipped into a
leather thong
the man paused to be spanked playfully
by a partner with a flog
what are they doing my curious kid asked
as our toddler cheered them on
the pair was the first of a few dozen
kinksters who
danced down the street laughing together
as they twirled their
their whips and batons some leading
companions by leashes
at the time my children were too young
to understand the nuance of the
situation
there's no nuance at all but she says i
told them the truth
that these folks were members of our
community celebrating who they are and
what they like to do
now she goes on to argue that the kink
community
quote unquote has always been a part of
pride and that it's
good that they be allowed to be
authentically themselves
in public that's certainly one way to
describe people who like to act out
their sexual fantasies
in front of children i mean is that what
she'd say about a man
masturbating on a park bench near a
playground
hey he's just being authentically
himself in public
as it turns out not everything that's a
part of your authentic self
is meant to be done or displayed in
public
defecation is an aspect of everyone's
authentic self
and yet we don't do we do we do that
right with the door closed in the
bathroom
unless we live in san francisco which
maybe this lady does
the author again her name is lauren
roello and you you should remember her
name in case she ever tries to come
within 50 yards of your children
continues from many paragraphs
describing the wondrous benefits of
allowing elementary age children
to watch gay men and leather thongs flog
each other in the street
skimming through some of this she says
quote i agree that pride should be a
welcoming space for children and teens
but policing how others show up doesn't
protect or uplift young people
instead homogenizing self-expression at
pride will do
more harm to our children than good when
my own children caught glimpses of kink
culture
they got to see that the queer community
encompasses so many non-traditional ways
of being
living and loving if we want our
children to learn and grow from their
experiences at pride
we should hope that they'll encounter
kink when they attend
how else can they learn about the scope
and vitality of queer life
children who witness kink culture are
reassured that alternative experiences
of sexuality and expression are valid
no matter who they become as they mature
helping them recognize that their
personal experiences aren't bad or wrong
and that they aren't alone in their
experiences i can't think of a more
relevant or
important reminder for youth who often
struggle with feelings of isolation and
confusion
as they discover more about themselves
and wrestle with concerns
about whether they're normal enough
she can't think of anything more
relevant or important to tell kids
there is nothing more important than
instilling in our children a healthy
appreciation for
sadomasochism she thinks
lauren rorello does does acknowledge the
critics of her position but she labels
all of us
anti-kink advocates that's what you are
if you
if you're horrified by what i just read
to you you are an
anti-kink advocate you might not not
have even realized that you held that
position i mean
if you simply don't believe that adults
should be engaged in sexual
role play and bdsm out in public in
front of three-year-olds
you are now an anti-kink advocate now i
have no real problem
with that label personally except that
i'd prefer maybe
anti-degeneracy advocate or anti-child
grooming advocate
um or anti-leather-clad weirdos spanking
each other in view of third graders
advocates
any of those labels will do though
really i i prefer to be defined in the
positive
i am uh anti all of those things but i'm
also a pro
sanity pro basic human decency
advocate most of all
lauren roello is very much on the other
side of the sanity and moral decency
issue
she's just opposed to it um totally and
s has already been made clear but a
deeper dive into her biography and life
story gets expectedly dark
and weird and disturbing very quickly
rowello
is a former prostitute we should just
remind you again i just
this this is a person who was published
in the washington post
okay she's a let me tell you about her
for a minute here
she's a former prostitute who now
identifies as quote
gender vague she's married to a man
who now identifies as her wife and is
transitioning into a woman
and her young son as she recently
announced proudly on twitter has just
started experimenting with makeup
and has declared his intention to appear
on rupaul's drag race one day
he's like eight years old this is a
family
utterly consumed in a tornado
of dysfunction and delusion and her
children are caught in the middle of it
being used exploited
in abused times of course they'd be
taken from the home the kids would
and their parents would put in prison i
mean those kids would be better off
in foster care they'd be better off in a
in a loving home with adoptive parents
but
even foster care would be better for
these kids
than being in a home with these abusive
parents
but that's not going to happen these
kids are condemned
to this abuse abandoned by the system
and by society
like so many other children it it it's
even worse than that not only are they
abandoned to the abuse
it's not just the people are looking the
other way that'd be bad enough
it's that people are applauding it
can you imagine that as a child being
abused in this way and exploited in this
way
and everybody standing around applauding
if there's any good news to be sifted
out of this insane disgusting mess
it's that the general reaction to
roello's piece has been
to put it generously extremely negative
now while the curated and monitored
comments under her article in the
washington post are largely supportive
funny how that works the feedback from
the wider internet has been
much less so as it turns out most people
don't think it's okay to intentionally
expose your children to naked men
in dog leashes spanking each other on a
street corner
and that's good that people aren't okay
with that but we shouldn't
slip into complacency because of it
because first of all it's a rather low
cultural bar
when we feel relief that most people
don't think bdsm
should be a spectator sport for
preschoolers like the fact that
that i'm seeing such a negative reaction
to it and i'm going phew
that shows you how low the bar is
second just because most people have
retained their sanity on this
issue for now that doesn't mean it'll
stay that way
there's a reason the washington post ran
this piece they knew it would get this
reaction that's part of the reason they
ran it of course for the clicks but
also the goal is to shift the overton
window to impose
perversion and degeneracy from the top
down
powerful cultural forces beat us over
the head with this
and at first we yell out and say stop
but they keep doing it and they keep
doing it until many people get numb to
it
and eventually decide that it must not
be so bad after all
and while they shove this filth in our
face and in our children's face
and in their own children's faces they
of course always accuse us of being the
ones obsessed with the issue
if we articulate an objection to it
it's gaslighting it's a slight of hand
trick saturate us with this stuff
all the time and at the same time try to
convince us
that we're weird or strange for noticing
or caring
the point is that the cultural changes
we're witnessing
and this is one of the most important
points for us to understand
the cultural changes um the cultural def
deformation i should say most of it is
not
organic it's engineered it's
orchestrated it's imposed from above
it doesn't require our enthusiastic
participation not at first anyway that
comes later
at first all it needs is our
acquiescence
and this is how they go about getting it
and it's worked
every time and will continue to work
until we wake up and recognize the game
as it's being played now let's get to
our five headlines
all right um man
i feel ready for another vacation it's
been such a long time
only a minute i'll be gone tomorrow i'll
be back on wednesday so it's
july fourth weekend everyone's gonna be
gone on monday company holiday
so two additional days i don't think
that's much well what really happened is
we uh
uh we were up at uh lake house in new
england
and my my wife and kids are still there
i left them there or rather they stayed
there and i and i flew home and now i'm
going to fly back
and then and then we're all going to
drive home after a couple days that's
what's going on
so i've been you know i've been in this
dark
studio for hours a day just writing my
wife's been on the lake
she sends me pictures all the time it's
so nice here
i'm so happy for you glad you guys are
having a good time
um and then uh and then that'll be it i
won't i won't leave again
i promise i'll never leave you after
this week
let's uh let's begin here since we're on
the topic
uh in the opening uh there's there's
kind of a
a segway here i suppose unfortunately
this is from the ap
it says pennsylvania's highest court
threw out bill cosby's sexual assault
conviction and opened the way for his
immediate release from prison wednesday
in a stunning reversal and he was
released from prison
in a stunning reversal of the fortune
for the comedian once known as america's
dad
ruling that the prosecutor who brought
the case was bound by his predecessor's
agreement not to charge
cosby now
um getting to the reasons
we know the background of this he was
arrested and charged and convicted of
of of rape and really this is a serial
rapist who's
abused many women but he was convicted
for for one of the cases anyway
it says justice david wecht writing for
a split court said cosby had relied on
the former district attorney's decision
not to charge him when the comedian gave
his potentially incriminating testimony
in a civil case surrounding this
this accusation of of rape the court
called cosby's arrest and affront to
fundamental fairness particularly when
it results in a criminal prosecution
that was foregone for more than a decade
the justice said that overturning the
conviction and barring any further
prosecution
quote is the only remedy that comports
with society's reasonable expectations
of his elected prosecutors and our
criminal justice system now
i don't have um i don't think i have a
lot of valuable insight on the legal
aspect of this
i of course everyone's uh outraged and
upset that bill cosby is out of prison
i feel the same way it's clearly he's a
serial rapist he deserves to be in
prison he deserves worse than that
so nobody is happy that he's out of
prison
but you hear a lot of people saying that
this is this is a miscarriage of justice
and this is the justice system
failing and all these kinds of things i
i don't know if that's true it depends
on the the legal arguments here
and i would let maybe a legal expert not
that i'm one to fall back on experts
here but at least someone who's
studied the legal matters here more
thoroughly
make those kinds of judgments but if
what they're saying
is that bill cosby
gave essentially this confession
based on an agreement with the
prosecutor that he that he wouldn't be
criminally prosecuted for it
and then he was well yeah it would seem
to me that's something you just can't do
as a prosecutor
that's uh that's a mistake the the
dysfunction and the
the miscarriage of justice happened with
with with that it's the mistake
that the court made and how they went
about this
um and we also wouldn't want that kind
of
precedent would we or a prosecutor can
make a deal with you and say
all right we won't prosecute you and
then you tell them what they want to
hear and then they say no never mind
we're still going to do it
so there's the general sort of outrage
but whether or not this was the wrong
decision by the supreme court i don't
see how it was
unless i'm just missing something what i
will say though is um
there's many people on the left
who have started using this term rape
culture again
and it's been a little while since we've
heard that right
we didn't heard much about rape culture
it was a big thing during the me too
movement
and uh and in recent years especially as
the focus has moved to more racial
issues
they've kind of put that to the side and
now once again these same people on the
left are pretending to care about rape
culture
and they're saying this is an example of
rape culture
and how men you know get away with this
kind of thing
um i just think that's very interesting
because how many of of of the people
that are saying that
how many of them have whispered even a
word of protest
over the fact that i could pull a
million examples but here's just one
really egregious one uh the fact that
male sex offenders in prisons
in states across the country male sex
offenders and rapists and murderers
are being sent into women's prisons
because they say they identify as women
there are women right now as we speak
and not just a few there are many women
right now as we speak
who are locked in a prison cell
with a violent male offender sometimes
sex offender
you want to talk about rape culture
um you want to talk about women being
silenced
men getting away with this kind of thing
if if you're not saying anything about
that
or the men that are being allowed into
women's locker rooms
and women are getting berated and told
to keep to keep their mouths shut and
just deal with it
you don't like this naked man parading
around that's your problem
you don't like it leave it's your issue
he has every right to get naked in front
of you
yeah that kind of thing if you're one of
the people making that argument
or looking the other way while this
happens then uh no you don't you don't
get to pretend to care about
quote-unquote rape culture
you don't get to pretend to be outraged
about this bill cosby situation
or you could pretend i can't stop you
but you're not going to have the
the the privilege of being taken
seriously we'll just put it that way
all right speaking of people who can't
be taken seriously number two gwen berry
was uh on
some kind of show she was the olympian
turned her back on the national anthem
the hammer thrower
i'm not even sure what show this is but
she was defending she finally after like
a week
has come up with some kind of defense
for her behavior but i don't find it
terribly persuasive let's
take a listen well originally we were
not even supposed to be on the podium
during the singing or the playing of the
national anthem
when we were back in the call room the
directions were
that we were going to be introduced to
the crowd um before the anthem was going
to be played
or after the anthem was going to be
played no one made any mention
or any notion that we would be on the
podium or had to be on the podium
during the singing of the national
anthem i want to make that clear
those were our directions either before
or after
no other event group that i know of
stood on the podium during the plane of
the national anthem
however when we went out to introduce
ourselves to the crowd
coincidentally the national anthem was
playing and they asked us to stand on
the podium
and then the anthem played in that
moment i feel like
it was a setup because i was those were
not the directions
that was not the intent the intent was
we would be introduced to the crowd
either before
or after the singing of the national
anthem
in which if we had that option or if i
knew
that i was going to be on the podium i
would have chose something else
now i just want to ask what is it about
the national anthem or that whole
scenario
that made you feel so uncomfortable why
didn't you want to uh you know
acknowledge that part
history if you know your history you
know the full song of the national
anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america
our blood being slain and and piltered
all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
huh it's obvious there's no question
well if you know your history the third
paragraph
of the as she puts it of the national
anthem talks about blood being
what was it slang and
piltered is it the horse she used
blood being piltered all over now i
admit um i don't
know the uh the third and
there are i think four to stanzas
national anthem
um like almost everybody else i know the
first one i don't know the others by
heart
um but when i first heard that claim
from her i i immediately knew
that that can't be right because
piltered is not a word
it kind of sounds like a word that could
be a word it's like it's like the kind
of word that you you you throw out in
scrabble
just on a flyer and you hope that no one
challenges it because it kind of sounds
like it could be a word
so you give it a shot because you got
that you got that triple word score
in reach and you just throw pilter down
and someone goes
pilter what is that oh yeah pilter wait
you've never heard
you've never heard the word pilter are
you serious go ahead and challenge it
you'll lose a turn go ahead i don't care
that that whole move but as it happens
um
pilter is is not a word i actually did
look it up because i thought i almost
felt like
am i having a stroke or something is
that that to me sounds like that can't
possibly be a word
i i did actually google it just to make
sure i'm not wrong on this
not a word i can confirm that um
what does the national anthem actually
say what is she referring to
so let's read i'm not going to sing it
but let's
let's read the part that i assume she's
referring to
um it says and where is that band who so
vauntingly swore
that the havoc of war and the battle's
confusion
a home and a country should leave us no
more their blood has washed out their
foul footsteps pollution
no refuge could save the hireling and
slave
from the terror of flight or the gloom
of the grave and the star-spangled
banner in triumph duth wave
over the land of the free in the home of
the brave it's actually a great
uh it's actually beautiful
notice nothing about being piltered all
nothing is being piltered all over the
floor
i don't know what it would look like for
a thing to be piltered and the reference
to slaves
and hirelings okay that that is not a
reference
to african slavery
i go back to what we discussed at the
start of the show yesterday
okay she says people need to know
american history she obviously doesn't
know
a damn thing about american history um
and this is
by the way backing up again um
this cl this was not her reason
for turning her back on the flag she
turned her back on
on a flag just out of a general sullen
sense of
i hate america and i don't know why
really it's i hate myself
um and i'm projecting that those
feelings of resentment
and and failure i'm uh i'm i'm
projecting them out onto america
that's what a lot of this is about all
of these morons who hate america so much
and it's and at some level they do feel
that way
but um these are these are basically
like kids
who go around saying no one likes me
everyone hates me
that kind of thing but uh so
that was her reason for doing it and uh
then she did it and she got this
this big big negative reaction and
backlash
and for the last few days she's been
looking for a reason
and she probably she looked up the
lyrics of the national anthem
and she discovered for the first time
that it has other stanzas and then she
saw the word slave in there she said oh
oh yeah this is the reason this is why i
did that
but as we discussed yesterday um
the form of slavery that existed in
america
the the type that she's referring to
horrible thing
not the only kind of slavery that's ever
existed on the planet
this existed for slavery has existed
existed as an institution across the
world for thousands of years
so not every reference to a slave
is going to be about the slavery of
african slaves in america in this case
it certainly isn't
this verse is talking about clearly
talking about the british here
they are the band that so vauntingly
swore
right they're arrogant and haughty and
all of that
like those damned brits tend to be
and um and the hirelings and slaves are
a reference
i seems to me to the fact that the
british have the british army had
mercenaries
and men impressed into duty against
their will
as opposed to the volunteer forces in
america
so it's kind of a dismissive reference
to the british forces saying oh they're
hirelings and slaves they were forced to
be there these are mercenaries
as opposed to the free men who
volunteered for service
for the united states that's what it's
talking about
it takes a little bit of of translating
and interpreting the flowery language
but it's pretty clear
not a reference to african slaves
so the reason she gives makes no sense
but it doesn't matter because again this
is just her
really this was a gut visceral reaction
because she does she hates her country
she hates the country that she's
representing
and going to represent the olympics
next here we've got representative gina
powell in
ohio she was proposing an amendment to a
bill which would ban
biological males from female sports
uh the kind of bill that again if you
really are opposed to rape culture
you want to protect women it's kind of
thing you should support
and she was she was talking about this
and her democrat counterparts had i
thought a very intelligent response
as she was talking about this amendment
let's take a listen
the chair has the amendment the
amendment appears to be in order the
representative may proceed
wonderful the save women's sports act is
a fairness issue for women to be able to
achieve their dreams and athletics in
our state
and is crucial to preserving women's
rights and the integrity of women's and
girl sports
across our country female athletes are
currently losing scholarships
opportunities medals education and
training opportunities
this amendment will require schools that
are part of the ohsaa
to designate separate teams for
participants
of the biological sex no school
interns no school interscholastic
conference
or organization that regulates inner
scholastics
shall permit biological males to
participate on an athletic team
or an athletic competition designated
only for biological female participants
that that really is their whole argument
because what representative gina powell
is saying here and what she's advocating
the amendment it it it
there is there there's no intelligent
argument against it
doesn't exist that's why if you've
noticed
all of the all the arguing that goes on
over these issues should there be men in
women's bathrooms should there be men
in women's sports should there be men in
women's prisons a lot of arguing
and we know on our side we're putting
forth arguments that make a lot of sense
arguments based in biological science
based just basic sanity logic reason
moral decency on the other side there
are no arguments
they have nothing so they do that
instead
i don't like this job that's the whole
argument
hey it makes my tummy hurt
do we have i think there was a second
video that actually shows the guy doing
do we have the second video
can you remember if i sent that to you
please okay okay
okay here it is i want you actually see
the guy who was doing that
um and uh and it just
yeah here it is here
what is he even saying
this fat overgrown baby
this fat old baby sitting there with
this
suit and tie
he can't even their argument is so weak
that they can't even articulate they
can't form words
even they're now at the point of
grunting
like cavemen
what else do you have you might as well
just do that
i want to see a formal debate about the
bathroom and women's sports issue got a
conservative on one side
left us on the other and the leftists
the whole time just does that
bottom no no hello
and look at this guy he's how old's this
guy 70
yeah this this fat old 70 year old
is probably with first of all
i want to know why do you feel so struck
why is it so important to you to get men
into the women's locker room
and women's bathroom and into women's
sports why why is that so important to
you as an old guy
what's going on with you that you really
feel that passionately about it
and when did you decide this i don't
know who that guy i don't know who that
idiot is
but i'm gonna i'm gonna just a a wild
guess here
that um he spent like the first 50 years
of his life
at least never mentioning this issue
or expressing any discomfort with the
fact that there are male and female
bathrooms and sports teams
and now he has decided like so many
other democrats who have been in public
service
for decades never brought it up
and now it's the most important thing in
the world to them
i'm sorry yeah usually i don't resort to
body sham oh i do probably that's not
true i resort to that kind of frequently
um but here i just i have no respect for
you as a man
nothing but but contempt and disrespect
as a man taking this position
all right um this was something uploaded
to twitter by
an account called uh my mixtapes with a
z
my mixtapes it's apparently
the the rapper kodak black
and uh he we could see him here
the footage he's on a boat and he's he's
chucking a hundred thousand dollars into
the sea that's what the twitter account
says a hundred thousand dollars
and he's simply throwing it into the
ocean throwing money into
this is essentially what everyone does
when they go to an apple store same kind
of effect
as a side note unrelated but i was
thinking about taking up scuba diving i
was actually thinking about that
totally unrelated i might get into it
like this afternoon
anyway you can see the outfit and and
the hair it looks like he might have had
an
unfortunate encounter with like a
malfunctioning tie-dye machine
at some point rappers all started
wearing sparkly
pink neon colors and unicorns and stuff
at some point rappers started dressing
like my eight-year-old daughter
my daughter has that exact same chain
too i don't know where she got it
i could tell you something this kind of
financial recklessness
is something that you'd never see from
my guy poo sheisty
or frankly from spottam gotham they
would never do this
uh what they're gonna do or at least poo
is actually rather than throw money into
the ocean
you know if you have money he will
actually steal it from you he'll he'll
shoot you
in the butt and and take it according to
the allegations
by the way this guy kodak black i should
also mention
um the guy in the my little pony
jumpsuit throwing money into the ocean
he got a pardon from donald trump
it was one of trump's final acts as
president anyone explain that to me
one of the final things that donald
trump did as president
on his way out rather than draining the
swamp or anything like that he pardoned
that guy and last thing to consider
um how would people react because this
video
was up on twitter and it kind of went
viral and people were laughing about it
okay a hundred thousand dollars he's
thrown into the ocean rather than giving
it to his community
you know he's got people in his
community poverty-stricken
homeless people on the street kids that
uh you know
are are are hungry and instead of
paying a hundred thousand dollars he's
just gonna throw it into the ocean
you can see that you can see the city
and the battle know what city that is in
the background
um there are people in that city right
now
that city who could use that money but
he throws it into the ocean i'm just i'm
i'm
i'm wondering if this was a white
fortune 500
ceo on a boat with this
with a city skyline in the background
throwing hundred dollar bills
into the ocean what would the reaction
to that be
would anyone be laughing about that
something to consider um
finally someone who's got uh plenty of
money himself though
in fairness i don't think he's throwing
it into the ocean robert l johnson the
founder of black entertainment
television and america's first
this is article advice by the way i'm
reading america's first black
billionaire
wants a check he wants it from the
government and he wants it to come with
an apology for slavery
jim crow and hundreds of years of racism
the 75-year-old media magnate
uh owns several homes heads in asset
management firm was the first black
person to own a majority stake in an nba
team he doubts
that the check will ever come but he
sees a new kind of reparations
being called by a different name so as
not to be divisive or controversial
happening already it says the new
reparations is critical race theory
education
it's the housing grant program in
evanston illinois it's the five billion
dollars of targeted support and debt
relief for black farmers
and it's the 50 billion dollars in
corporate pledges in the wake of george
floyd's
uh murder dedicated to combating
systemic racism and equation
and inequality so the article says
that's uh and johnson is saying that
that's a form of reparations that's
happening right now
but that's not enough he wants the
actual check
this billionaire wants a check from you
if you're a white guy i don't know
working as a as a a plumber or something
robert johnson wants you to pay him he
wants you to contribute to the kitty
uh throw money into it and so that he
can get a check
but what i what i really what jumped out
of me when i read this article
aside from the the silliness of the
reparations idea
and and silliness i think puts it is a
generous way of putting it
but i thought critical race theory
wasn't being taught in schools isn't
that what we're being told
isn't that what places like vice have
been insisting
that this whole thing about critical
race theory it's all it's all a
far-right narrative it's not even being
taught
it's this is really kind of an esoteric
legal theory and it's got nothing to do
with education
and now you're saying oh it is being
taught
but it's a form of reparations
well which is it because those are two
very different things
either it's not being taught at all or
it is being taught
as a way to uh as a as a form of
restitution for slavery
very different all right let's move now
to reading the youtube comments
um
uh one comment says they got sheisty i
smell a setup from the feds
probably white supremacists too stay
strong matt free poo
yeah i want to see those bumper stickers
and shirts free poo because this is
this is a serious i wish trump was still
in office so he could pardon
uh pooh scheistie
maybe maybe biden will do it
cp says matt the egg you're talking
about is called balut
okay that's the egg with the uh
fertilized
like duck or chicken embryo inside it
that people eat in some cultures
but you're not allowed to that may sound
gross
but you can't say that it's racist
racist against two i don't know
racist against the duck embryo perhaps
um ian smiley says please do a push-up
contest on the next backstage episode
love to see walsh crush those nerds
then just jen says i want to see matt
challenge ben to a push-up contest we
all know that ben is shockingly amazing
at them
probably even better than matt well
we actually tied the last backstage i
missed the last one uh but
the one before that off air i was
actually talking about that with ben
and uh because he said he could do i
think he said he could do like 30
pull-ups or something like that
which is a lot i'm not gonna say it's
more than me
i i i plead the fifth on that
but i did float that that idea maybe
before backstage sometimes we should
have some sort of
physical fitness test or contest i'm
game i'm i'll throw the gauntlet
down right now i'm in i'm in
let's do it push-up contest me and ben
shapiro
um yeah i i like that i do all right and
finally this
says sorry matt but i think you're
somewhat deluded on the slavery issue
the fact that people practice evil and
barbaric
actions for thousands of years does not
make anyone in the past
less culpable we're not more culpable
because we're so advanced suddenly that
we
know that we now should know better evil
is evil wrong is wrong sin is sin
barbarism is barbarism in fact
those in the past who own slaves are not
excused because everyone else was doing
it in fact
they were so callous that they could
throw slaves into the arena to kill one
another for entertainment
um we were talking about the romans now
go a little bit further back
my mother taught me the fallacy of the
belief of that belief from the time that
i could first talk okay
no i didn't say that uh that people who
practiced slavery historically
for thousands of years when it was an
accepted institution across the globe
i didn't say that they were without
moral guilt
and i didn't say that it wasn't wrong
back then
gab i believe in objective morality i'm
not a moral relativist
so what's evil is evil for all time and
slavery has always been evil it's always
been the same amount of evil
okay it wasn't like less evil than it is
now
it's always been extraordinarily evil as
evil as a thing can be
um and nobody who engaged in it
or practiced it is uh
is innocent um
and however you put it excused
i didn't say they should be excused no
but when you're assessing moral
culpability
personal moral guilt for an action
you have to take things like historical
context into account
you take a lot of things into account
they do this in the court system or at
least they should
when they're passed in an ideal scenario
when they're passing down a sentence
they're trying to make a judgment in
part we already know okay they've been
convicted of the crime we know that
whatever the crime was we know it's bad
let's say it's murder well part of the
issue in sentencing is how
to what extent are we placing moral
culpability on this person
we know they're morally culpable how
culpable
so these are questions now in the end
only god can really judge that and say
for sure
but i think we can make general kind of
reasonable assumptions and judgments
and so when when you're talking about
someone
in history let's just pull any 500 years
ago let's say
um and they're living in a society
where from birth this was an accepted
and normal institution
i would say they have less not none
less moral culpability than someone born
today
into a society where they're told from
birth this is a horrible thing
if in spite of being told that from
birth you still do it
i would say you have even greater moral
ability than someone who's born into an
environment where
where it's considered acceptable this is
not it's not any kind of radical
idea this is something that on
in most subjects people would agree
they have to judge people within the
context of their time
just on an issue like slavery we want to
you know make an exception
to that common sense judgment and i just
don't think we should
um there are you know you also have to
keep in mind
there are there are certain moral
insights
that maybe you have arrived at in your
in your life
kind of on your own uh but there are a
lot of others that you were
that were instilled in you from birth
and you don't really get credit for
those
ideas like racial equality slavery is
bad these kinds of
we take it for granted because we were
born into a society where this is what
we're told
from birth this wasn't like some
brilliant idea that you had
you were told that and it's a good thing
that you were
but people born in a different situation
i just think we judged more called
ability differently
you know in today's day and age it seems
men are short
on examples of what real men are uh well
you have me at least
that's one thing you've got going for
you but in fact you only need to glance
at social media for a second to see the
standards being set for boys these days
like men parading around and singing
lullabies as characters of
over-sexualized women nickelodeon
that's why daily wire started a new
podcast to illuminate the heroism of our
brave
biological male ancestors it's kind of
sad we have to
stipulate that it's called america's
forgotten heroes and the first episode
concerns union soldier joshua lawrence
chamberlain
who dashed directly into history at the
battle of gettysburg by strategically
charging the confederates and narrowly
dodging a bullet
that grazed his cheek on the way his
actions were pivotal to the union
winning such a hard-fought battle yet
many americans don't know his name
just like so many other important
historical figures that you've never
even heard of so
if you didn't already know his name
remember it now because men like
chamberlain
are more than just men they're legends
and they're the reason america is as
free as it is today so subscribe now to
america's forgotten heroes
on apple podcast spotify or anywhere you
might listen
also the daily wire has several open
positions for our in-house
team in nashville this week the position
we're highlighting
is uh we got a few openings in fact in
our post-production department
including a video editor position as
well as an assistant video editor
position
the video editor will use his or her
technical technical and creative
abilities to cut and assemble raw video
footage from various daily wire projects
yes including the matt wall show to
creatively support
and emphasize subject matter in videos
through compelling editing and
storytelling
a minimum of two years professional
video editing experience is required for
this opportunity
i don't know why they need to ask me to
do this maybe because i don't know
anything about computers at all
i can barely even turn mine on it turns
off and i gotta call someone in here to
figure out how to turn it back on
the assistant video editor will assist
our team of video editors by pulling and
assembling media cuts performing quality
control and cuts and much more
so these are full-time in-office
positions in nashville tennessee
candidates should apply through
dailywire.com
careers a link to your real and or
portfolio is required for consideration
for both of these positions
so go again to dailywire.com careers now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to be canceling
gop house minority leader kevin mccarthy
and the other 66 republicans in the
house who voted to remove all statues
from the u.s capitol which depict people
who joined the confederacy these are
these are not statues of random
confederates mind you each state has
sent a statue of someone who represented
them in congress
usually a historical figure from a
century or more ago and many of these
statues have been standing in the
capital for a century or more themselves
now we should also note that some of the
confederate statues quote unquote
and and the phrase confederate statue
here is a little bit of a
of uh is a little misleading
because many of these statues
memorialize men who served in congress
after the war was over
okay a statue of wade hampton was sent
by south carolina for example he opposed
secession but remained loyal to his
state when it seceded and became a
brigadier general of the cavalry
uh for the confederates in the three
decades that he lived after the war he
served as governor u.s senator and
railroad commissioner
joseph wheeler was sent by alabama he
joined the confederate army eventually
rose to the rank of lieutenant general
then after the war became a lawyer and
eventually a politician he served in the
house from 1881
all the way until 1900. these are not
all people who are known to history
solely as members of the confederacy
uh many of them had distinguished
careers after the fact
that they were members of the
confederacy as a reflection of the fact
that they lived in the south
so what congress is saying today is that
southern states
simply are not allowed to honor anyone
who lived in
or served their state from the middle
part of the 19th century
up until the beginning of the 20th
basically congress has decreed or will
decree once the senate votes
that these states must look elsewhere to
find people to memorialize that is to
say
other states are telling those states
which historical people they may or may
not choose
and many republicans 67 in the house
alone are on board with that plan
including kevin mccarthy who while going
along with the democrats agenda and
joining hands with the mindless
statue toppling hordes thought that he
might at the same time
try and flip the script on the script on
the democrats by pointing out
that the confederates were democrats
themselves
he's got them now whatever will they do
back against the wall let's all watch
and bask
in the rhetorical brilliance of kevin
mccarthy watch
the defining time of our nation the
greatest challenge ever to
our constitution was a civil war long
and by far
the bill we're voting on today we voted
before
and i supported it i support it now
but let me state a simple fact all the
statues
being removed by this bill are statues
of democrats
madam speaker as i heard the speaker
talk earlier about removing of the four
portraits of speakers in the hall
the same answer goes for that as well
they were all
democrats what's interesting the
statutes that
need to be removed were sent to the
capitol
by states that were majority controlled
by democrats sent
to a house that had a majority
controlled by democrats
accepting of these statues
i think the bill should go further
maybe it's time the democrats change the
name of their party
they may be desperate to pretend their
party has progressed from their days
of supporting slavery pushing jim crow
laws
or supporting the kkk
but let's be honest at any place at any
time if those
fundamentals rest somewhere
we cannot let them
what is the the kind of preacher
cadence he's got going on why do
politicians do that
where the voice goes up and then it
trails off and then you pause
then it goes up again i support what you
democrats are doing
i will go along with you 100 i will give
you everything you want
i will cooperate fully but also
you're the real racist ha
i win didn't see that coming did you
let me deliver a news flash to kevin
mccarthy and any other republicans still
beating this particular dead horse
uh nobody cares that slave owners 200
years ago were democrats
nobody cares i know you want people to
care
i know you care i know you think this is
a clever point to raise
nobody else cares nobody even cares that
democrats are the ones who enacted jim
crow
and supported segregation much more
recently
democrats have encountered this tactic
many times you aren't throwing them for
a loop
he's so impressed with himself while
he's saying all this
but you aren't saying anything that
hasn't been said already and you aren't
causing even one single person
anywhere to reconsider their allegiance
to the democrat party
maybe that talking point should have
that effect
but it doesn't and in general when you
go with the
you're the real racist approach you're
now arguing on their turf
on their terms you are playing a game
that they
invented you are in their stadium now
the refs are bought and paid for by them
okay this is like playing in foxboro
the cards are stacked against you to mix
metaphors the fans are all on their
side
you're not going to win this mud
flinging match it it is it is far
better far more effective far smarter
not not to mention far more dignified i
think
to refuse to play the game entirely and
in this case refusing to play the game
means standing up there and saying no
we're not going to remove the statues in
fact we don't support removing
any statues anywhere unless it's a
george floyd statue
or a statue of the petrous harvey milk
in san francisco
or somebody like that those statues we
can get rid of
but all the statues you people want to
remove we say no
none of them why should we say no well
four reasons number one speaking out
specifically about these
so-called confederate statues which
again is a misleading way of putting it
the first thing to keep in mind is that
many of these states were already
going to replace those statues with with
someone else
without being told to do it maybe not
right now but soon
the democrats know that they know that
most of these statues are not long for
this world
one way or another and uh and that's why
they're coming in now and demanding that
the statues be taken down
they they would the statue of jefferson
davis for example example
in the us capital that that's coming
down anyway
but they would much rather the spectacle
of republican-controlled states being
forced to take down their
their confederate statues in shame at
the behest of their democrat overlords
they'd prefer that over allowing those
states to do it themselves on their own
terms
because they choose to do it they want
they want the optics
of uh and we're going to see this soon
when this thing goes through
of those statues and there's gonna be
cameras all around
and i'm sure nancy pelosi will be
standing there triumphantly watching
as the statue of these very statues come
down
arms folded
well they wouldn't do it so we had to
that's the point this is all a political
game for democrats that's all anything
ever is
their stated motivations for doing
anything are never the real motivations
they're always thinking about the
political optics and good for them
frankly
they're in it to win it while
mush-brained republicans stumble along
doing as they're told while muttering
vague protests as they do it
second thing the left-wing mob should
never get what it but what it wants
you should never do anything at its best
anything i don't care what it is if
they're outside your door with
pitchforks tomorrow
morning demanding that you wear blue
jeans that day and you were already
going to wear blue jeans you should put
the blue jeans back in the drawer and
wear khakis instead
the left-wing mob wields unprecedented
power in our culture and the only way to
break that power is to defy it
i've said this many times about the
statues even if there's a hypothetical
statue that by that by its rights
objectively
warrants removal you still should oppose
its removal under these conditions
at the best of these damn people
number three we should absolutely reject
the claim that everyone who served in
the confederacy is now automatically
precluded
from receiving any public recognition or
or memorialization at all
we should reject that that's not how
we saw it as a country for nearly 150
years after the war
and the left tells us now that we have
to see it that way for nearly 150 years
it was generally seen that um
the war was a terrible time in our in
our history
when honorable people fell on either
side of a great rift
rift and uh and and blood was spilled
and there was brutality and evil but
there was also dignity and courage and
honor it was understood that a man like
robert e lee for instance
was not a proponent of secession was not
some sort of rabid defender of slavery
but he lived in virginia it was his home
it was his family's home
when faced with an awful choice
he decided to fight alongside his family
his sons his community
rather than against them that was a
choice he faced
he could take up the sword um
against his own sons
or alongside them now seeing that choice
again in historical context
it's maybe not so hard to understand
even if you would have chosen
differently or think you would have
chosen differently
and yet in spite of that we could still
remember robert e lee as a great general
and an important historical figure
and for 150 years that's how he was
remembered
now the left comes along after all these
years and says no you know what
that point of view is no longer allowed
you can't you're not allowed to feel
that way anymore
many conservatives bow obediently and
say yes sir as you command
i don't think that should be our
response
four finally um i don't know how many
times this has to be communicated but
apparently at least one more time it
doesn't end here
the more you cooperate the further it
goes
if we're removing statues of people who
served in the confederacy even if they
didn't themselves own slaves
is there any special reason why we
wouldn't or shouldn't remove statues of
people
who didn't serve in the confederacy but
did own slaves like thomas jefferson
what about people who didn't own slaves
but were outspoken racists and white
supremacists like abraham lincoln he was
a white supremacist
a stated white supremacist
there is no reason why with this
precedent
it shouldn't be applied to nearly every
historical figure who made the mistake
of being born in the 19th century or
earlier or even the 20th century or
earlier
with at the rate that we're going now
some of us said years ago
when they started taking the confederate
monuments down from parks and so on
that soon they're gonna they're gonna be
going after the founders
and we were right we predicted it
how did we know that do we have
supernatural powers
did marty mcfly show up from the future
and tell us about it no
we are just able to understand the
concept of precedent
and we also know how the left operates
we know that it's called progressivism
because it always progresses it never
stays still it must always move must
progress
progress not in a good way but like
cancer progresses
we know that if you still don't know
that
still have not figured that out you are
without excuse
for your obliviousness and stupidity
and also you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator
is mckenna waters the matt wall show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021.
the house gop leader supports tearing
down confederate statues
the politician and philosopher donald
rumsfeld dies and a pervert washington
post columnist exposes her children to
kink check it out on the michael knowles
[Music]
show